this week the FAA told Congress that
final regulations for business use of
drones would be done by the middle of
next year and of course this comes as
investment in drone companies is taking
off VC firms have too pumped more than
210 million dollars into drone startups
so far this year and pim it's
interesting because some companies
actually had to say no when VC firms
tried to hand the money because they had
enough to go around yeah I would in fact
I was reading the bloomberg article
about this the company is arrow sign a
ROC I and II and they've got a drone it
weighs about 30 pounds it has 12 motors
they said no thanks we've got the money
that we need right now but there are a
lot of companies taking money remember
the drone incident where the drone was
tracked in the White House it went on to
the White House lawn at terra cotta
right yeah that was made by a chinese
company a DJI technology they got a
valuation of about eight billion dollars
because companies like google as well as
venture capital companies like you know
kleiner perkins mm-hmm all investing
money in drone companies because i say
this is going to be a big market when
those rules are concluded once the rules
come out then we can actually start
calculating and quantifying how much
money they can make all right